ce qu'on appelle une zone à urbaniser en
priorité la sud de montpellier la
paillade une forêt de pierre et de béton
au coeur de cette ville nouvelle
une vraie forêt avec de vrais arbres et
une grande maison au charme
indéfinissable la maison de sophie
desmarais
jean-paul liddell qui avait son bureau
en dessous de 2 c ça fera alors bon il
se disait bonjour il parlait puisqu'il
était producteur tous les deux et un
jour jean paul vidal bien ça ferait vous
préparé quelques chevaux face à
l'albanie les affaires ça mal à tourner
le film
la résurrection c'est bien celle c'est
bien mais la résurrection
ça l'a un peu d'argent qui s'alarment au
betis est elle appelée trottoirs aux
basses et les vraies vacances de famille
ça veut dire en a la chance d'avoir
cette grande maison alors on a des tas
d'amis qu'on aime beaucoup
j'ai mes filles de mon petit fils j'ai
des copains de mon petit fils qui est
quelques classiques qui viennent se
baigner avec nous j'ai faim j'ai dit
c'est la famille quoi je n'ai pas joué
la comédie depuis plus d'un an puisque
je me dis bon après quatre pièces sur
jardin qui m'avait bien bien l'épuiser
c'était un rôle très dur je me suis dit
un an de vacance est le paradis mais
maintenant faut retravailler et nous on
ne vit pas d'amour et d'eau fraîche mais
l'aurait la rentrée comment ça se
prépare
robin la rentrée c'est hélas pour dans
le bijou déjà vu je répète d'ailleurs je
travaille à discuter parce que je
m'amuse mais je travaille en même temps
j'en enregistrais ma pièce s'appelle la
main passe et je m'entends j'apprends
mon technics a des oreilles
je voulais qu'on ne travaille alors sa
part de marché si sûr avions pourtant
c'est l'exacte vérité
alain mouret pourtant c'est l'exact
méritée parce que c'est une pièce c'est
une pièce très amusante
c'est peut-être une des clés si drôle
que jamais les à la lecture de sa map s
est fait tellement réellement l on la
travaille ans c'est formidable c'est
d'une logique d'une drôlerie d'une
efficacité fantastique ça je voulais
femmes à l'assemblée si lourdement
dormira si gentiment après avec la
satisfaction de l'oubli devoir accompli
un physicien dit c'est vraiment est
cocasse et puis alors il ya toutes les
les idées de feydeau ça veut dire que il
a toujours aimé la mécanique les et les
objets curieux il ya le fauteuil est
extatique dans la dame de chez maxim où
il savait où tout le monde reste comme
ça
c'est d'une logique vous savez quand on
s'extasie sur ionesco qui est évidemment
un croate auteur mais on pense qu'ils
ont vraiment lu ça avec beaucoup
d'attention je suis persuadé qu'ils
gagnent est ce qu a été influencé par
c'est drôlement et c'est pas le seul oui
stearman ça me fait drôle que tu me
dises voûté près de 2000 et me laisse
pas son rallye feydeau 2/10 bac se passe
on dit puisque tu as rêvé tout c'est
très drôle et pas choper des
facilitations je suis aie jamais c'est à
même d péri parce que j'ai trop loin
d'être obligé d'en maîtriser mais
pourquoi lancer douze faut porter des
prières de rue parce que se dire je
laisse pousser les cheveux pour le
deuxième acte où je ne suis évidemment
chemise de nuit au lit donc j'ai mes
cheveux longs et je veux pas avoir de
longue perruque parce que je trouve ça
côté wagnérien qui est affreux grosse
perruque arfa j'aurai mes cheveux elle
râle du temps pour être bien coiffée
j'aurais dit ce qu'on appelle une
brioche savez
on pense à au titre d'une pièce d'andré
roussin que vous avez joué qui
s'appelait et s'appelle hélène où la
joie de vivre chaque fois que je vous
vois se fit j'ai toujours envie de dire
se fit ou la joie de vivre
j'aime bien vu enfin j'aime bien oui
j'aime bien vivre quelquefois je trouve
ça fatigant
et puis je rapidement un second souffle
levé ce privilège rare c'est de savoir
encore regarder les choses autour de soi
vous voyez j'ai fait très attention
comme on dit ici vous savez contempler
comme femme pleure